to me television commercials were
profound for 50 years my big thing is
why are we continuing to put yesterday
on a pedestal and tomorrow on a pedestal
people would rather spend money on
potential metaverse and AI stuff and
commercials instead of actually focusing
on today today is how you're actually
going to build your brand and today
perfect creative and media execution
across the 10 platforms that are
referred to as social media sites is
disproportionately the opportunity
social media is just a slang term for
the current state of where the attention
of consumers are and we need to
understand how to be good at it today's
title so we are going to get straight
into to the question so today's title
that we set was building businesses
through social and uh we know you're a
massive Advocates
um for social channels and so I think
the one to start this off because we've
got so many marketeers in the room is
when they are approaching marketing or
your observations what are the most
common mistakes or learnings you think
with that approach to marketing and
social
so we're just going to go there right
from the top straight in look I think
everybody in this room whether you work
at an agency whether you're on the brand
side you know I would argue and this is
you know a tough way to start the
conversation but I would argue that we
are in a very nascent State on marketing
and social I believe that most large
organizations call it the Fortune 50 000
you know big companies
um that less than one percent of them
actually take social marketing serious I
think they're checking the box I think
the entire industry of advertising has
it upside down
um everybody's creating brand
positioning than a TBC and then pushing
down into digital and social
predominantly with matching luggage to
match what they came up with in a board
room without any
understanding of the platform nuances
the the opportunities to be using the
creative tools that the platforms like
yourselves and your competitors have
created to make content they are
completely missing the understanding of
what social can do when it comes to
winning on relevance
they're obsessed with the notion of
scale and awareness when most brands of
that size have plenty of awareness
they're not losing an awareness they're
losing on relevance and consideration
what does that all mean it means what
everyone's missing is actually
respecting the platforms you have CMOS
and CEOs around the world talking about
how social media needs to be regulated
by governments because it's so powerful
and then when it comes to them using it
to Market it's like the fourth thing on
their list and they post [__] like happy
Tuesday
oh
and and with the mix also between paid
yeah and organic
um how what examples have you got or how
do you see your recommendations on
getting them to work together and get
them to work well and also just thinking
about the the rise of creators and the
role that they're now playing well
creators are in the complete opposite of
what I just said they don't even know
any better than to use these things
properly and then grow
creators don't know about programmatic
banner ads creators don't know about
planning upfront television buys
creators don't know about buying
Billboards creators don't know about
mixed modeling mixes and Millard Brown
case studies and and so they're they're
the rise of them is obvious because they
know how to use these platforms
and by the way I am not overtly in love
with social media on the record I'm in
love with consumer attention it just
happens to be on social media right now
obviously I'm sure this is not news for
anyone being who I am and what I do and
living in the United States I am
unlimited bombarded over the last month
of like what it what do you think about
if Tick Tock expand what's gonna happen
if Tick Tock gets banned my answer to
that is like that's above my pay grade I
have no idea what you know China and
Russia and America are doing with
themselves but
but it
began
all that attention just goes somewhere
else
and so like to me we're not out of
business if tick tock we're not out of
business if every social media
disappears attention goes somewhere it
was on the radio back in the day then it
went to television now it's on the
internet the current state of the
internet is social media the metaverse
may happen one day this company has it
its way then plenty of people will be
living in you know Horizon and Oculus
you know I think that's an inevitable
outcome I think the question really is
timing is that three years from now is
that 13 years from now but this is all
about attention and what creators
understand is the attention sits on
these platforms and to remind everybody
the attention is free
the attention is free and it's more free
than ever now because you and your
competitors and the other platforms now
reward quality creative to get more
organic reach because your job and your
competitor's job is to keep people on
your platform so it's better to give
people what they actually want versus
the alternative
so it's becoming more important
meanwhile the ad products continue to be
grossly underpriced because unlike the
rest of the ad world that creates
artificial floors of cost television
print radio websites digital most of you
and your competitors add product is
based on supply and demand
so for example not because I love you so
much at meta but because I love being
right I've been yelling for seven weeks
10 weeks 14 weeks about Facebook reels
being grossly underpriced because they
are
because they're incredibly underpriced
because there's a stunning amount of
attention on Facebook reels but a
misunderstanding of it from the Creator
and the brand you ecosystem of how much
attention's there thus there's not
enough content being put on it against
the demand thus everyone who's doing it
gets more awareness over time that will
be figured out it will neutralize and
then you see what always happens in
every platform the organic reach is only
a function of supply and demand now it's
a bigger function of the quality of the
content which is a huge opportunity for
all of us and then the ad products on
top of it are incredibly underpriced and
in the post iOS 14.5 world with tagging
and you know cooking now the creative
becomes even a bigger variable because
the best practice now is when on
Creative see that there's an indicator
that there's interest and then post
produce that asset into a performance ad
and run media against it
so the playbooks will continue to change
and ebb and flow but creators understand
it
what do I think about the organic media
I'm you and the competitive landscape I
think the far majority of it is
underpriced
the problem is the creative industry
that we live in doesn't know how to make
creative at an appropriate price
the ad world is broken
creatives too expensive
and so brands that are Fortune 500
Brands can't take advantage of the
social platforms because of creative aor
doesn't know how to make volume creative
at a cost that's efficient against the
distribution that's in front of us
and that's the elephant in the room and
how do you think the agency should be
thinking about that and by not ripping
off their clients anymore
and we need to put our process is that
correct you don't you you don't have a
price
you don't have a price that's the best
thing about you
you don't have a price
you're not television you're not print
you're more like Google you don't have a
price you have a tiny entry 10 cents
five cents whatever the impression is
but like you don't have a price
unfortunately the holding company
creative agencies have a price
it's called a ton of money for people to
sit in a room and bounce ideas off each
other
I said I was going to ask two questions
but but you know the energy of this talk
is not pointing fingers or anxiety it's
opportunity
the reason the world sits in this
Bizarro landscape where big Brands would
rather
m a small Brands into their
organizations
then do the work that the small brands
are doing is completely predicated on
the disconnect between the agency and
brand ecosystem and it doesn't have to
be that way
it just doesn't have to be that way and
I think um I think the industry needs to
step up the ad industry needs to step up
we need to provide more value to our
clients you know I'm aware that there's
only five or six holding companies and
it's in essence I'm not happily within
each other I get that but it's not
sustainable or it's going to be a
problem in a 10 15 20 year window and I
understand that the executives that run
those companies don't care they're going
to be retired by then so that's fine but
there's a reason companies go out of
business and this is what it looks like
you can't spend seven million dollars a
year in Creative fees to get one video a
year for television and they get
matching luggage for social in 2023.
makes no [__] sense this is very
important I don't think people are bad I
don't think they're even I don't even
think people are ill intended I just
think the great I think the advertising
industry has to look itself in the face
and say do we have our clients best
interests in mind or do we have our best
interest in mind
programmatic black boxes that are just
sitting with tons of margin for our
media agency is not in the best interest
of our clients buying badinventory on
dot coms running media that doesn't
understand the creative that's being run
on it and having those two separated
these are not real smart things to do in
2023 and and honestly I've talked a lot
about the platforms that I've talked a
lot about the agency but at the end of
the day the person's fault in this
entire ecosystem is the brands
there's the ones that write the check
and so that to me is the most
fascinating part
like
you know you you get what you pay for
and you know to me I think
the things that bring me passion and
interest and drive me and make me want
to do this this morning is to create a
dialogue that's missing
I did this in the wine business wine was
overpriced when I got into it premium
wine in America was overpriced and it
didn't need to be that way and people
didn't like the conversation but it
ended up being true
and it helped the consumer I really
struggle with the advertising industry I
don't think the brands are in a good
spot I think they're losing market share
and I think they're going to continue to
lose market share unless they adjust to
the title of this which is social media
is just a slang term for the current
state of where the attention of
consumers are and we need to understand
how to be good at it and I think
everyone in this room knows the far
majority of big businesses are not good
at it
they're just not
I think it works great that you're so
honest in the approach and even though
I'm sure some of us have sat here being
slightly
thinking wow what have I done with my
career and where am I going well because
I think because to that point I just
really want to make Clarity in this
because
what you didn't you know back to 20
years like 15 years ago it was different
five years ago like it's different to me
it's not about like oh we wasted our
time I mean television commercials were
profound for 50 years very Roi positive
my big thing is why are we continuing to
put yesterday on a pedestal and tomorrow
on a pedestal people would rather spend
money on
potential metaverse and AI stuff and
commercials
instead of actually focusing on today
is what's interesting today is how
you're actually going to build your
brand and today perfect creative and
media execution across the 10 platforms
that are referred to as social media
sites is disproportionately the
opportunity disproportionately
well we've done anyway
and I would love
um to open it up you know we've got
marketeers and we've got agencies in the
room so it's really great to have some
questions uh for Gary who wants to raise
their hands and we've got some mites
that we will pass around
there we go we've got a couple we've got
one here and one there and one there
okay uh
we talk thank you nice to meet you being
a big fan thank you what's your name
Alex Alex nice to meet you yep likewise
um well I think what are you saying
about the traditional Addies model I I
completely yeah I'm on the front side
now with new technology like you know
generative Ai and stuff GC like brand
favorite thing that it's our own hands I
do I think the big elephant in the room
that no one's talking about is copyright
and trademark of where this is like
we're the most Progressive we like to
think and Vayner and we are absolutely
not prepared to use AI creative for
clients because we don't know the source
and we don't want the liability so I
think there's a lot to figure out of
what's I mean the amount of litigation
that's about to happen against open AI
is going to be pretty profound the
biggest companies in the world that have
their IPs sitting on the internet are
not interested in somebody selling it to
the people they're selling it to we went
through that with Google and this is way
more intense than what happened with
Google and so I think that um I
definitely think there'll be a day for
that but I think there's going to be a
half decade of clarity of what is
allowed and not allowed that I think at
the Big Brand levels I think
entrepreneurs are doing it now
small businesses direct to Consumer
brands that use your platform's property
properly they're already using AI art
right now for their ads so I think you
know we're gonna have to navigate
through this but it's a big exciting
technology which means it's also scary
to a lot of people
um and you know I'm excited about it I'm
genuinely think it's some of the most
profound Tech I've ever seen and it's
just starting and it gets smarter so
it's going to be big league stuff but I
think as far as advertising I think for
the biggest agencies and the biggest
brands there's going to be some proper
hesitation here until we get some legal
clarity
sure
so you gotta explore the first question
what's your name my name is Cynthia so
nice to meet you nice to meet you so you
kind of stole the question that I had
was which type of technology that
excites you for the future of
advertising but my second question is
more about your kind of long-lost middle
child being there three and whether or
not this is kind of your play for
tomorrow or today so you just mentioned
Banner 3 is our play for today beta 3 is
one of the vaynerx holding companies
it's a bain and McKinsey Consulting type
of company for really at first it
started for nfts because I'm extremely
enthusiastic about web3 but it's really
now morphed given the market conditions
and you know it's a you know anytime it
reminded me so much of Internet 96 the
hyperbole
outpaces the reality and so and then
this one had greed in it people selling
and so right now Vayner 3 spends a lot
of time on AI spends a lot of time on
even things that are a little bit more
mundane QR codes I think are still
continuously under utilize and
misunderstood uh AR VR
um and what we're really doing there is
actually what we just talked about it's
not our bet on tomorrow it's our service
to our biggest clients to not waste
money on tomorrow
so our positioning for Vayner 3 is we
are really about this life
let us come in and educate your decision
makers that write checks so that they
don't waste money like it's you know
listen I'm pretty darn bullish on the
long-term metaverse but if a brand
spends two million dollars to do a
metaverse execution right now and
expects consumers there they're in big
trouble
and so we're doing a ton of education
and Consulting occasional execution uh
specifically in AR and QR code
um but for example we have a lot of
clients who are paying us who we were
the people that told them the legal
issues with AI and they stopped doing
something that could have you know and I
always get proud of that like one of the
things you felt for me in the first 20
minutes of this talk is I think it is a
requirement of a human being to be
passionate and
proud of what they sell
and and that's my biggest issue with the
ad world that when Alex is on the brand
side
he can speak that way but when he was on
the agency side it was harder and he had
to figure out how to balance that
because you that's not judgment that's
empathy
when you're on the when you're selling
something that you're not completely
convinced is right but your family's
lifestyle is built on it you're paying
off your debt because of it like I don't
cast judgment I deploy compassion to
that but I do have deep passion and
conviction that you need to believe in
what you sell
so you can imagine for me when we're
selling a three hundred thousand dollar
four month retaining Consulting product
to teach a Big Brand about Ai and we
start with legal realities and they stop
a campaign that's about to be done by a
creative agency that just for the adage
headline I'm very proud that they just
saved themselves the potential of a
seven million dollar lawsuit by our 300
kakamanian dollars I believe in that and
so I'm really excited about Vayner three
and a lot of it is based on hey have you
fully thought this through are you
actually thoughtful back to happy
Tuesday
as opposed that a lot of you laugh too
the reason I use that as a reference is
the reason vayner's winning the way
we're winning is we do creative on
social with substantial strategy
I laughed watching Brands take great
social media in-house and not
creative in-house creative aor you just
have to hire one creative director and
one strategist and you now have
replicated creative aor social is hard
these social in-house agencies are a
great thesis but in reality
it's one of the hardest things to do in
the world right now to understand the
platforms and the culture of every one
of these platforms like dude I'm sitting
in New York spending 10 hours educating
myself about lying in Japan like on a
monthly basis I mean this is complex
[__]
so
um vayner3 is not our play for tomorrow
it's to mitigate the risk for our
clients today
foreign
you talk about you know the attention
span moved up through the whole digital
era and now it's right now the attention
is on social uh we're building a brand
uh which is a Cape Cod what it does is
it provides in-app social consumer
experiences like through a GPS legendary
so with news feeds uh any social
component right so technically yeah you
know as I said uh you know consumer apps
that is intrinsically social harvested
in these days right so I just want to
understand your perspective on you know
having centralized social medias already
you know Top Notch uh the attention is
already laid out there but now there are
a lot of companies who are trying to
bring in Social ego for example bringing
that social component I follow you you
call me as tradies right so how do you
think this whole digital evolution is
happening and that you think as the
world moves forward the attention span
also values to Illusions apps where
in-app groups you know engagements could
happen anymore I I do think to you what
you're referring to that there's
possibility of that as a collective
taking a percentage of that attention
but none of the individual ones will be
able to have the network effects to
create the real consumer behavior that
is associated with it so to your point
an API that creates news feeds within
every app in the world depending on the
nature of the app
will have different levels of success
Uber having a news feed
how much people use that or not I don't
know a sports app having a news feed
makes a lot of sense because you have an
affinity around a hobby and you you
could see that no different you know
when I hear your pitch and my brain I'm
like oh that's cool because I think the
opportunity there is to actually go
after message boards I mean message
boards continue to be real around
affinities and so I've read it became so
substantial so we we are tribal that's
what everything that's going on in the
world is about and so micro tribes
within apps that have the functions of
news feeds is a really clever thesis my
belief system is the biggest elephant in
the news feed game is a decentralized
social network is definitely a
fascinating thing to think about right
the complaints that people have of your
company Tick Tock and others you could
see a hypothesis of the consumer being
fascinated by the concept of a social
network that's decentralized and you
know they're naive it's scary to me how
many people think Mark sits behind some
sort of like Wizard of Oz thing and
pulls the algorithm the naivete of the
consumer is fascinating
um but I you believe in that naivete
there is some ideological Intrigue by
the concept of that
um but yeah I I think there will always
be fragmentations there's there's people
who still watch commercials there's
people that still see print ads there's
people that still listen to radios my
point isn't that nobody's watching them
my point is that they're expensive
my point is that nobody's not watching
them my point is like is it the best use
of your eight million dollars to buy six
million dollars of media of a television
commercial and then spend two million
dollars to produce a 30-second spot
that's my argument what will that eight
million dollars look like if you did it
more contemporary so I think to that
same point I'm sure there's tons of
opportunity for micro communities at
scale and attention being fragmented to
those places I think that might become
your defense okay we'll do that you got
it
so we loved having you here I think that
was in 2020. We did an interview
um with you and Dan and one of the real
talk gems that you dropped on us was
this idea of being practitioners yes
right and so you just kind of spoke
about it in the comment before the
question to you is as we have seen more
Brands more companies I'm sitting next
to my friend here from
sk2g go in housing right yes kind of
take some of that on do you think that's
helped in terms of where the either
producing better work or better
understanding of either the platforms
and the respect that it deserves
wondering where the progress it hasn't
materialized to My Hope
you know what has happened is it's saved
some dollars this was the Great
Miss of the creative agency aor they so
underperformed in doing social creative
and it was so overpriced often hidden in
the creative aor fee that it led to your
friend and others to decide to take it
in-house the problem is your friend and
others continue to not take the platform
as serious as brand positioning and
television and push down
and what's even scarier is the strength
of agencies is the fact that they see a
lot of things
now in-house is only focused on their
brand
the truth of the matter and I say this
with all respect the level of strategic
thinking about the creative and the
platform nuances is absolutely not there
on the in-housing I I watch all of it
and and I because you can see the output
you know when you really are a
practitioner it takes you 30 seconds to
audit people's social and you can
absolutely have a quick sense of what
they're up to and do the other there are
brands in this room that don't have a
URL linked to their Instagram account
do you know how insane that is
so
um I I think it's helped in saving them
money where they were getting ripped off
so I love in-house for that but I think
they're doing it just as badly as their
creative aor was
I really I genuinely do and it's mainly
because they don't have enough resources
they hire one or two good people and
like
I have 33 full-time employees on my
brand
there are 33 full-time employees that
work on garyvee's content
what else do you want me to say there's
not a brand in here that has that many
people in their in-house
team
and when they do like it gets real
efficient inefficient real fast I looked
at one so we created a Consulting
product to consult in-house teams
because back to like being proud of the
dot like I don't want to [__] on
in-house teams by the way I think every
brand in the world should do everything
in-house
but you have to be able to do it
right so we started seeing the trend and
we said you know what let's start a
Consulting product because we really do
know this this is the one thing we will
stand on this is what we know let's
create a Consulting product and we're
not trying to convince people to unwind
their in-house and work with us we'll
try to make you better and so we've
really taken those meetings over the
last two years
even we when we're fortunate enough to
find people that know what to do they
don't have the resources and the
politics are absurd right you know like
like when you're the head of social
media inside of iconic brand like his
the lead creative decision maker is
looking at you as like some third tier
like you know like not you know people
are cut you know but that's the truth
like they're not thinking that that and
I think that's where brand is being
built brand is being built in Social
but nobody wants to open up Pandora's
Box because we all want to go to the
south of France in eight weeks and look
at each other and Make Pretend We're
[__] good at something
I mean do you know that these creative
like cheap creative officers think
they're famous
do you know about this everyone this is
like this is like the wildest thing I've
ever seen in my life
creative officers of creative agencies
and advertising I think they're famous
there's not a single normal human being
on Earth that has ever heard of one
Chief creative officer in advertising
oh
yeah I think we had a couple sat there
together no it's a couple by the way
sorry
it's awesome
um
so I'm from Mala we are the fastest
growing music sharing producing platform
in the world well and
um my question is more also on what she
was kind of hinting on yep it's getting
like quality content comes basically as
a product what is that product ideation
look like for you
um just like not the point of like okay
it's scheduled or is it like
programmatic or kind of like how does
this disperse from hey got an idea I
want to make sure I understand the
question one more time I want to really
grasp it sure so in terms of quality
content quality content got it um how
does your ideation process got it I got
it so here's how I see the world
a brand has a brand positioning we have
to respect that work has been done you
have to have some sort of point of view
respect next
and most importantly and the biggest
issue I have with advertising the next
thing in our framework is what's the
business objective I mean I've said
plenty very direct things here I'm going
to say another one most agencies don't
actually care about trying to make
especially on the creative side
they want to do the creative idea they
have they don't care about driving the
business so the framework for me doing
social brand building and building
businesses is what's the brand stand for
what's the business objective the next
thing we do is we create 40 to 50
consumer segmentations
not three
right 40 to 50 consumer segmentations 18
to 22 year old males living in
Bangladesh that are into Esports
21 to 27 year old females in Tokyo
making 200 000 a year
40 to 45 year old moms in Malaysia who
have an affinity towards High fashion
real specific consumer cohorts with real
teeth
okay next on that is called pack
platforms and culture
like do you actually understand what the
platforms are doing next which platforms
are you creating for you've now gone the
whole way down now it's we're gonna pick
Instagram and Facebook and Twitter and
for me every brand that's in this room
should be on all of them
but this is back to allocation more to
their dollars go
so they can't but they should but they'd
rather spend eight million dollars on a
TV spot
so you lay out the platforms then
you go to work so now you create a
framework now your creative and strategy
team are ready to work now you start
posting against
the framework right you know what
consumer you're going after you know
what you're trying to achieve in
business you know how the platforms work
so you know Facebook reels is
underpriced right now you know that
green screen headline creative is over
indexing on Tick Tock you know
so you start making now the work really
begins after you make you have a person
your strategy team called the PCS a post
creative strategist her and his job is
to look at all the qualitative feedback
you have your analytics and media team
look at the Quant feedback and you start
making your machine smart like a half
pregnant AI
the team gets smart through the work you
start looking at the proxies when you've
got a retail brand that sells in retail
stores you're running the media against
hold out clusters to prove that you're
actually driving incremental growth if
you have a DTC brand or an app it's a
piece of cake you're just looking at the
black and white data when the creative
goes viral or over indexes its Norm it
becomes the brief for more
efficient and effective work so now the
virality based on the consumer sentiment
and intent and truth becomes a proxy to
your brief not a strategist sitting in
an office going on Reddit for four hours
writing a brief
then you do that forever and ever and
ever
your cohorts are an accordion as you
start getting affirmation that
something's not working you actually
eliminate Malaysian moms 40 45 because
you aren't finding Affinity your
creative team hasn't hit the mark on the
flip side while marketing to Indonesia
Gamers 13 to 15 you realize it's
actually the female Gamers 13 to 15 that
are even more interested in the intent
and you create a new cohort to go there
to double down on the truth of the
consumer not The Audacity Of The
Boardroom
that's how I do it
was there a second question
I knew that was in the same space as
I've been on that little rant just for
the room think about how fundamentally
different that is than 99 of the
execution of social media marketing in
our industry
that's how big the opportunity is
I agree hi my name is
thank you I am just asking questions
about the left field please conversation
please
um I changed for your four and a half
years ago from the secondary school
teacher and then I went to my very long
journey actually with meta and I'm now
currently with Microsoft
um two weeks ago I was speaking at
Stanford about that journey and about
the education system and that
intersection with technology and I guess
my fear for the future is that we really
don't understand the opportunities with
technology and Innovation and how to
educate the masses
um so I just like your thoughts on that
I'm actually the reverse of that I've
never been more optimistic
for the first time ever
smart parents aren't forcing their kids
to go to Stanford
so I understand what you're saying I
actually think we're in an inflection
point we are truly truly in the pre-dawn
of parents around the world finally not
putting University on a mandatory
pedestal which is creating a level of
curiosity and a level of thoughtfulness
and a level of self-awareness and a
level of actually auditing children that
is going to lead to incredible happiness
for children and much better education
not how education is sold
we also are demonizing AI at education
levels at scale so hard and so fast that
there's going to be an over correction
and understanding that what AI is
actually doing is forcing our children
to critically think
and input instead of memorize and figure
out the system
I think that higher education is a new
phenomenon as a business as a business I
think education is the most important
thing in the world I think the greatest
thing that meta ever did was accelerate
and be one of the companies at the
Forefront of the world talking to each
other which has led to profound
education I'm aware that currently we
are focused on all the bad things that
humans are about and we're blaming the
platforms for human behavior that's a
different thing on the flip side we have
never lived in the world a better
education
when you start a sentence with big fan
you and I would have never known each
other 50 years ago
we have connected humans there's so much
Beauty to this you know many people are
married happily forever because of these
Technologies you know many people here
are more educated than they could have
ever been because these Technologies
I've never been more bullish on
education because I think we're about to
tear down over the next 50 years the way
education has been packaged weaponized
sold and have extracted an enormous
amount of
happiness out of society
I'm going back to your previous
conversation please sure
um
so a key thing that brands are after is
reach yes and that's something I mean I
believe in it the most
I believe in it the most
[Music]
um when we're looking at reach and cost
per week we're getting that very
efficiently on a TV platform no you're
not at the beginning at least what we're
thinking I think because there's a third
party verified
solution to it that's right yeah it
means that you've believed in the proxy
yeah you've bought into you've bought
into the grp you're not getting
efficient reaching television you're too
smart for that you're getting potential
reach you're not getting actualized
reach how do we conquer that by using
your common sense
no [__]
you know we're having true dialogue here
how do we counter it the smart people in
our industry which is rampant start to
actually think for themselves and not be
robotic about something they know is not
true
do you know many people can explain a
grp in this industry
you're not getting reach
it's not being consumed
it's a tree falling in the forest right
now you're not getting reach you're
getting potential reach the problem is
there's too much margin in it for the
people selling you that reach
but we need a report to tell us that I
know that's why you're losing market
share
because you believe a report versus the
truth
but that's not that's not because we're
stupid it's because it goes back to the
thing I said about Alex it's because
it's the currency that drives your
business
people's bonuses are attached to those
reports
you know we have eliminated Humanity
from corporations
I believe there is a Nirvana called
companies will just hire smart people
and trust them to do the thing that they
want them to do that does not exist
today
we are not getting I refute to the last
breath I have that we're getting reach
on television in 2023. we are getting
reported reach we're getting potential
reach and deep down I think everyone
knows it and by the way digital is no
better
like like programmatic banner ads and by
the way news feeds too like you know I
don't look when I get 47 million views
I'm like I got 14 probably you know like
you know like but the difference is
every time I hold out cluster and
suffocate I still do direct mail and
television and outdoor for the my family
liquor store business and many other
things every time I hold every activity
to accountable business results
traditional media shits the bed and
social media Done Right dominates
right that's the part that people
haven't figured out of this conversation
there's so many people you're a
comfortable business results are what
sales
because I do media and creative together
I didn't trick you into separating it
really fun to be in the agency world
when you've got media and creative
separated and they each blame each other
within a holding company
oh that was funny right
this industry needs a reality moment
you know very honestly I'll probably be
out of it sooner than later like I
really don't give a [__]
I just want to be historically correct
I could care less if any of you become
clients or we I really just don't care
I just want to be right
because it feels better
you know we're not getting we're not and
we're not getting it in programmatic and
if you if you if we started to actually
want accountability we have to bring
media and creative back under one house
and hold people accountable to our
business results at the end of the year
the separation of media and creative
destroyed this industry it made nobody
accountable to nothing
and what this industry is built on is
headlines and magazines and reports that
are completely full of [__] this company
was built on Datalogics report that was
the biggest bunch of [__] of all
time
but it allowed companies to start buying
Facebook because that report was like
okay well trust this everything was
[__] row as that to its ass and it
wasn't true
but the industry accepted it and so it
became the industries Nielsen ratings
for social that's fine because at least
this was a better use of dollars but
we're just not doing the right things
you know
no television is not efficient reach
it's a waste of [__] money
thank you you're welcome
we got one more question
we've got Walmart here unconscious
attack GoPro hi Gary my name's Eric I
welcome our mastering platforms here in
Mata I really is a straight point
question how do you think about
attention and messaging and how should
Brands think about it it's a really
interesting one it was funny when you
were talking about um and he's got 15 on
Instagram I almost jumped in and said
and I crush on WhatsApp
um I think about messaging a lot but I
think you know this since it's what you
do there's so much trepidation for
Brands to get in there because it's a
private place
right AI is going to be interest like
you know when I tell you I'm desperate
to get in there
man if I can mark it in WhatsApp I would
do it every hour on the day because the
attention is insane
right the text I don't know if you know
the startup Community
um which is a text platform you know I
have two three hundred thousand people
that you know have given me their cell
phone number that I text on community I
get like 94 conversion rates on certain
things when I do the Creative right
there's no I I'm OG for you youngsters
in here I used to do email marketing in
1996. how many people here actually have
been close to email marketing in their
careers just raise your hands nice get
ready
1997.
a hundred thousand people on my dad's
wine newsletter that I'm asked because I
crushed
92 open rates
that's impossible now
that's what can happen
in text
when we find a way to get in there but
I'm too empathetic that consumers in
1996 the reason I had those open rates
were
people were just like so happy about
everything right like like email hadn't
been ruined yet right you know now
consumers are cynical private I mean I
don't have to sit you know we've been
through it in this company I've been
through it in this industry we've all
been through it so
people are hesitant to let us in there
you know I think I've been thinking a
lot about this I think WhatsApp should
take a page out of Twitter desktop pre
mobile ad product which was if you
remember
Twitter's ad product in like 2008 or
nine I know there's some youngsters in
here but let me give you some history
lesson it was mainly a lot of desktop
consumption and on the right side they
had 10 trending topics and then above
that they added a an ad product called
sponsored Trend or tweet right and so
you could buy
that spot and it was a monster I was
back to when everyone's like what is
social media like I was buying that
image and it was expensive but the
attention was so absurd I think a very
simplistic very lightweight what's that
product that had a little tiny Banner at
the top with one you know where the copy
from The Advertiser was all linkable and
you could you'd have to just buy the
whole network later you'll figure out
how to make it all contextual
I think could be interesting similar to
The Tick Tock ad when you open the app
and it takes over the whole thing the
world is struggling back to actual reach
which is why Super Bowl is you know it's
funny meanwhile comma and complete
opposite the Super Bowl ads the best ad
in advertising every single company in
America should clamor to spend seven
million dollars for 30 seconds in Super
Bowl because you have a hundred million
human beings actually watching with
intent for 30 seconds and even the best
day on meta and the best day on
Instagram and Facebook and snap and Tick
Tock and all of them come out I could
never get a hundred million people
assuming 30 full seconds for less than
seven million dollars and I'm as good at
buying modern comms planning and
spending media across the board as they
come and our organization is and you
could never do it so that's the best ad
I think WhatsApp putting that at the top
at scale globally because one of the
most interesting apps ad products in the
world if you think of global Brands you
think about like the World Cup gets
incredible amount of time like if I woke
up tomorrow and Peter Chun or Mar or
somebody from my team was like did you
see what WhatsApp did and I clicked the
TechCrunch article and it's there's a
new ad that's a tiny thin Banner at the
top of your messaging on WhatsApp and
it's on everybody's WhatsApp around the
globe I am calling Proctor Nike
Pepsi like in two seconds saying we need
to understand this now because in that
first little window of the first six
months to 12 months first three months
to six months everyone's gonna pay
attention to it and then it becomes a
creative variable game if you're a brand
that knows how to write the copy that's
compelling for someone to click it will
work if you're not you'll waste the
money Super Bowl is the best ad buy but
all the creative eighty percent of it is
a showcase for the Ad Agency not an
objective to drive the business and thus
it becomes a waste of money because they
spend 3 million on an actor they spent 2
million on some fancy director they paid
some production company to make it the
creative agency got incremental fee to
sit in a room and pontificate and so
I'm really struggling with creative
agencies as you can tell
because and by the way let me tell you
on the record I have a curveball for you
do you know why I'm struggling with
creative agencies because I interviewed
so many senior creatives and they're so
damn unhappy it breaks my heart
this is not making fun of this is deep
compassion and empathy to what's
happening the most creative people in
our industry are getting their souls
sucked dry by sitting around for nine
months debating with each other to put
out a piece of vanilla video on a
television set that nobody on Earth is
watching
that's a shitty existence if you're
creative
so
um that's what I think about
final final question okay
besides yes
um I'm a big fan thank you somebody also
a little bit critical yes and yeah equal
parts genius and something else if I
which is something else if you may
yes sir so do you in that case then
refuse the independent eye tracking
research that shows attention levels not
only but traditional channels like our
home but it eat all the independent uh
each individual ad format that's in in
platforms like meta and YouTube and Tick
Tock and all of the others and
um so you don't believe any of that
independency I'm guessing and the sad
part is you also don't believe any of
the peer-reviewed evidence-based studies
that have been done around econometric
monument that show the value of
no I respect that Here's my thought on
that I don't think anything is absolute
I really don't I think that this
industry has accepted the Counterpoint
as absolute that's one number two I
think I think eye tracking is very
fragmented there's some platforms that
have really strong technology there's
other platforms that have kind of middle
of the road technology that then also
rely on a little bit on surveying and
justifies it a little bit different
um my biggest argument Gavin is like I I
think there's a lot of ways to make a
lot of things successful you know I grew
up in the alcohol business I so I'm
always a little more interested in the
sector you're in and I'm always watching
there's a lot that can be done there's
there's I absolutely believe that there
is
sales that come out of traditional
executions my big passion point is but
at what cost compared to the alternative
so I I don't I've seen plenty of reports
that have matched the actual business
results and I feel calm and excited
about that every day of the week my
problem is whether it's Nielsen or
whether it's eye tracking or whether
it's data logic which is how the New
World Order got its start there's just
an extraordinary amount of reporting and
justification that doesn't match the
three-year window of the business
results
and there and of course there's other
variables let's call it Spate of spade a
lot of the companies that think they're
marketers and branding are actually
sales organizations your brands in the
US are heavily predicated by what the
distributors in the local market are
doing to so it's not just marketing that
could affect business so to your point
I speak with enormous conviction and
passion and deep belief
and there is no question at times
subconsciously I can probably go even
too extreme it's because
the entire Market has gone too extreme
in the other direction which is
completely in the face of like real
vulnerabilities that we need to talk
about so it's not that I refute
but I I will say
I really struggle with reporting overall
it there's just a lot of fake proxies
and what's even scarier to me is how few
people can speak to it
when you're trying to have a
conversation of understanding why they
spend all their money on it so back to
eye tracking the thing that got me into
a decent position was I knew nothing
so I was scared to sound like an idiot
so I went and studied everything
and so like to me I'm always still
meeting with every tracking and every
traditional metric and I think my
biggest struggle is there's a lot of
vulnerabilities in them we have to use
them as proxies all of them
at the end of the day
but I think it's just a ways of working
that the industry really needs to
challenge itself so you know I I think
it's a really thoughtful question I do I
really genuinely don't like absolutes I
think the world is absolutely gray not
black and white I just think we have to
take a step back as an industry and
realize we've accepted all this stuff
that has unequivocal data that says it's
vulnerable
so I think that's where the energy is
coming from
all right thank you thank you sir great
last question well I know there was lots
of hands still bobbing up but I'm afraid
we are at time uh Gary just want to say
a huge thank you uh not only of passion
comes across and uh and you know some of
the points you're making quite bold and
direct which I think sometimes we all
need to be reminded of but the bit that
I also really like is you're incredibly
compassionate as well so you have a lot
of acknowledgments can I say something
that I think will capture this all
the gentleman came up to me four or five
years ago at can and started to berate
me in the middle of the battle like you
don't care about this industry my father
grew up in it you don't care about the
work that just really really aggressive
and when he was done I looked at him and
said mate because he had an Australian
accent I said I said hey I said I said
I'm the only one fighting for this
industry and what I was trying to get
across to him and then we got into a
really nice conversation actually was
we're vulnerable
this is not fun for me to sit up here
and I don't I don't enjoy this the way I
think people think I'm I love this
industry I'm of this industry I've met
so many wonderful people that we compete
with that we work with that I really
think we need this combo
and we just don't have it going on at
all
we really don't and I and I I will say
this to the meta employees
it is your responsibility to be more
forthright with the agency and the
brands
I mean that I've been very genuinely
perturbed by the concessions that this
platform has been willing to do for the
industry and undermine their own product
for Revenue
we can do better
I I understand that you don't think they
may understand and I'm very empathetic
to you thinking they don't care it's not
going to matter anyway because it's not
in their best interest financially I
respect that but I I beg all of you to
take the higher moral ground and speak
your actual truth versus compromising
what's going to get the sale done
very much I love that you say you like
to be right my husband or sister said
about me so uh
cheers everyone have a wonderful weekend
thank you
thank you very much